so next is time to actually start that
learning process the fun part you know
and
the rough part at times but still the
fun part is it's the climb hello
everybody my name is nian i'm the black
female engineer provides content for new
and inspiring software engineers and
today we are talking about how to become
a software engineer in 2022
the fastest way the fastest way so yeah
let's just hop on right to it if you're
trying to become a software engineer
first and foremost when we're talking
about how to become one first take a
step back and think about what are the
things that when you were a kid you
always wanted to become what are the
things that currently you fantasize
about doing and yes you might say like
software engineering but truly take out
that piece of it and like what kinds of
things those type of work excites you so
here's an example as a kid i really
wanted to be a fashion designer and
looking at me now i still really love
the different aspects that designing and
fashion has to do with creativity and
that you know freedom and that kind of
fun with things as a kid you may have
wanted to be an fbi agent and that whole
thing of protecting your community and
being a part of i don't even know like
this this network of
the word secrecy
this network of intelligent people
trying to
keep the community safe a lot of people
don't realize software engineering is
just so broad it's such a large
huge blanket term
and if you want to become one be in this
you know nice little group it's
important to take a beat and try to
niche down because yeah software
engineer this great broad term but okay
are you a front-end developer or your
back-end developer are you a game
developer do you work with xmx language
there's so much inner workings that if
you come at it without a
clear focus it can make your route
towards software engineering so so long
because you're just out here learning
things willy-nilly not really connecting
it to a specific path because it is
those paths that's going to lead you to
the specific languages to learn another
thing that people don't realize or at
least i didn't realize when i was
learning not all languages do the exact
same things depending on what you want
to do and what career what type of
sector you want to be in different
languages are better for that you can
just say oh i'm gonna learn python
because everyone's supposed to learn
python you know what you want to be
let's say like a front-end developer
then learning python isn't that
necessary so yes start with the path so
going back to those examples if you used
to fantasize about being an fbi agent or
you currently fantasize about doing
something like that then cyber security
might be the route for you me i wanted
to be a fashion designer and so looking
at it now front-end development was the
right path for me to start learning how
to code and so take a second like truly
just pause the video and think okay
where does my mind go when i'm escaping
when i'm trying to go to bed when i'm
fantasizing or when i was a kid where
where did my mind go when i was asked
what do you want to be when you grow up
because i can assure you whatever that
dream is there is a field in software
engineering that can closely relate to
it which will make learning those types
of languages those languages that relate
to that field a lot more fun and
exciting we'll provide you with a few
languages that have been noted to be
super high in demand in 2022 and that is
python surprise surprise python java
javascript those are two different
languages y'all c sharp php and kotlin
and so those six languages have been
noted to be some of the most popular and
most in demand for 2022 and so think
about okay i really want to be in web
development i really want to create apps
so the languages to definitely learn now
if that's the case would be javascript
and it fits in with what you want to do
in a career in the field and it fits in
with the most in demand languages and
for 2022 because we want to learn
languages and everything but we also
want to get a job at the end of it i
mean i'm presuming you want to get a job
afterwards and so yes make sure that the
language you're learning the languages
you're learning fill those two buckets
what you actually want to do in tech and
that high in demand aspect if you would
like me to dive more into specific
languages that will be super beneficial
for 2022 and super high in demand the
types of languages that jobs are hiring
for let me know in the comments below
because it helps me know what you like
and what you want so please let me know
in the comments below okay so next you
have the specific type of work you want
to do as a software engineer and you
have the language or languages you are
going to start off learning i suggest
starting with one or two double in one
or two until you figure out okay i'm
going to stick with
this one for now and then move to this
one so you kind of sometimes it's best
to juggle two and see like okay actually
i i like this one more and just really
go on that direction and so start with
no more than two but then definitely do
niche down to one and so next is time to
actually start that learning process the
fun part you know and
the rough part at times but still the
fun part is the climb and so i highly
recommend starting out starting out
starting out with harvard's cs 50 course
on edx it was super low cost and i
started out with this course because it
provides just such a good baseline for
computer science this video is for
people not actually going towards the
computer science route in terms of a
degree however there's still certain
things you should know
that you may not know if you only go to
tutorials on udemy there's still certain
terminology to know certain concepts to
know that you really won't get without
being in a cult like college classroom
like the principles of things and so
it's important to take a second to get
to know those things if you want you can
do this maybe after you've dabbled in
coding a little bit so you can get that
and some feeling of getting your hands
dirty i know i like to do that i don't
like to just sit and listen to something
and
wait for actually getting to code i like
coding right away and so if you want you
can do this at the same time as you
doing other coding tutorials but i
highly recommend a course like that that
does teach the principles of computer
science that class does have other
classes to continue on to learning more
about computer science however i think
it's not super necessary if you go
through that one course and i'll link it
down below i think it provides a
fantastic baseline for things to know
okay so you've done that course and so
now let's now go to courses for actually
getting your hands dirty and development
this is where udemy can be great the
thing with udemy is you can kind of
it can be great and not so great because
on the not so great part it can kind of
be this i don't even know tutorial loop
of
your following along with what the
teacher is saying and doing but you're
not actually understanding the reason
behind things and why you're doing those
things but you're following along and so
at the end of the day you have this
amazing to-do list app but you
if you need to do it again you couldn't
do it or if you had to explain
what functions you use and why you use
those functions and x y and z how you
got to that end product you couldn't
really explain it which is not a good
thing however there are two specific
instructions i've heard nothing but
amazing things about and that is cold
steel's he has his web development boot
camp on udemy along with a bunch of
other tutorials and courses on udemy and
what's great about theirs is they've
released courses for 2022 so you know
you're getting the most updated concepts
and functionalities and skills being
provided to you via this course and
andre miyogi who has udemy courses for
python and web development i'll add
links to those below as well but i
highly recommend going through those
courses but also
make sure again you're not just
following along to these things and you
are truly
making sure you are comprehending the
whys behind things because if you don't
know the why at the end of the day when
you get hired
and it's time for you to solve certain
problems you're not going to know how to
solve them because you never understood
the y's from before and so if you don't
understand the y's from before you're
not going to know which things to
implement now for these current problems
and so make sure you're understanding
the whys what's amazing is we have this
whole world at our fingertips and so
really you should be able to google some
some some and figure it out especially
because it's a little secret in software
engineering
on the job
google is you your co-worker that i i
speak more to google than i do any other
person at my job so
being comfortable with that process and
asking questions to on google and on
stack overflow and whatnot is extremely
important and it is truly truly truly a
skill in and of itself and from there
start building
don't think that because you don't know
the exact steps to do something that
you're not ready to start building it
again in software engineering on the job
you are googling
constantly and so start building think
of an app you want to build i'll say a
to-do app again as an example say okay i
want to build a to-do app start with a
static web page of okay so here's the
header here is the design i want and
here is a rectangle where i want the to
do's listed then google okay how do i
dynamically add to do list items and
then how do i remove to-do list items
and how can users click on this
component to create this reaction of
okay if i click close then the to-do
list item disappears and google those
things step by step and slowly you'll
see how
drilling down to specific questions
really can make the development process
easier where you can't just say how to
build a to-do app but you think about
the steps that it would take get a
whiteboard and think about truly what
steps it would take to create a to-do
list on a conceptual level and then
start cranking those things down one by
one by one and that
yeah i'm gonna keep saying this that is
what you will do on the job there's a
myth that
software engineers they just know how to
do things like no they don't just know
how to do things they know how to find
the answers they know how to find the
answers and problem solve and that is
what really
when it comes down to it what software
engineering is also understand that
you're learning it's not a linear path
you don't say okay i'm going to be
an expert at css first before moving on
to javascript i'm actually using an
example from one of my commenters
commenters commentators
one of the people that wrote me a
comment i am
actually using them as an example
because they asked me this question like
okay when can i move on to javascript
i've been doing css for this long when
can i move on don't have the mindset of
i must be an expert at this before
moving on it's going to be so iterative
once you build your first one to two
static sites with css it's okay to now
move on to the next concept like
javascript however when you're going
through javascript and you start playing
around somewhere and building some more
then you may have to come back to css to
have a specific type of view you want
and then you may have to go back to
maybe html to be able to build tables
and then to be able to populate those
tables dynamically you may need to then
jump back to javascript and so don't
think that it's this structured linear
path like some studies are because some
studies are like that like being a
doctor you need to know certain steps
before you're out here sawing people
open you can't just iterate through that
but yes make sure that you understand
that you will be iterating through this
and you're not going to be doing things
in a linear path because that's not how
this is gonna go at all ever even at
work that's not how i was feeling and
then finally think about your timeline
this is a video about yes how to become
a software engineer in the fastest way
possible in 2022 however
it's not gonna go fast if you don't have
like a goal you know what i mean a
actual timed out goal of okay in six
months i want to sign my offer for a job
or in one year out to do x y and z if
you don't have that plan it won't flow
in such a structured manner because
you're not holding yourself to any type
of timeline i it took me
about exactly six months from me going
from one career to signing on a job for
in software engineering took just about
exactly six months total that entire
path that entire journey and so six
months is totally doable four months
it's totally doable three months
a year five years
it's more about
make sure you're putting that time and
effort in now make sure you have that
goal now and you understand that goal so
that everything you're doing to get
there
is following the timeline you want so
there you go everybody a very high level
overview of the steps to take to become
a software engineer in 2022 over the
next few weeks and months i will start
drilling down more and more into these
concepts like i said it would be a
three-hour video if i
went through all of it now and so i'll
make it more of a series i have a
similar series for 2021 and so check out
those videos but yes i want to do some
more things more relating to 2022 in the
languages and demand and learning
concepts and demand and things like that
so yeah please let me know what you'd
like to see let me know what your
questions are your goals are and i will
see you all soon thanks y'all bye